hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off now before I do
anything else I just beat sugar and it I
don't know why it took me this long but
people informed me that Zachary is not a
mix of the judge it's just that the
judge was very sad that I had to kill
his brother or that his brother was
killed and therefore as a curry took the
role as judge as my mentor and therefore
I shouldn't even give him the good voice
that I was doing and I'm an [ __ ] for
even trying to do that but a lot of
people also informed me and before I do
anything else I have to I have to get to
the top of this power and all you lovely
gentlemen over there you got a little
something on your everything so you
might want to get in private and clean
that up a little bit because I don't
think anybody here wants to see anything
about you
donc don't want to deal with you right
now I've got a lot on my mind like how
the hell I'm supposed to solve this how
am I supposed to purify everyone then
they do not want purified you know I
always suspected that there was
something wrong or there was gonna be
some sort of a twist to this game but I
didn't exactly know what it was gonna be
you're why I was gonna be that or I had
an idea that maybe there was gonna be uh
you know what I'm gonna go ahead and say
that I had no idea what was gonna happen
but I need to get to the top of this
tower because I don't even know why I
need it I found the thing before and I
have no idea wait a minute that that's
readable hang on one second
wait a minute are these still readable
or are these readable again why are they
readable again were they always readable
or wait a minute I thought the things
change from when the zone got purified
but if the story's okay that's easy
that's the same story right maybe maybe
it is I'm just gonna get to the top of
the tower because I I'm assuming that's
that's where the important bit of
information in this whole shindig is
right don't you yeah yeah so creepy
you're dead okay shut up voice in my
head don't bug me I need to get to the
top of this tower there aren't even the
space whales to comfort me not that the
space whales comfort me before but hey
or do you know I'm an idiot
so anyway I'm gonna get to the top of
this time I get to the bottom of this
mystery oh look it's another thing again
I can save my game and pretend like I
never visited this nightmare at all I
make a return Oh No oh there's a kitty
cat oh okay whoa what are you what are
you doing I am yelling if my lungs
fullest I could even argue that the echo
that reverberates back to me is the
voice of someone I know
have you seen my dear brother
this so sad
stop it sob stop haha I done bad but I
mean it wasn't me they killed his
brother
it was it was the Guardian who was good
that I did that I saved his brother his
mother wasn't his brother anymore he was
taken over by the thing and it wasn't my
fault it wasn't my fault it wasn't the
batter's fault either it was nobody's
fault it had to be done it had to be so
I'm I've been overblown Mike for a while
now but hmm I don't know I don't know
what to say to that I don't know how to
respond that's so sad
that is literally one of the saddest
things I've ever seen in my life I would
have I would have realized that Zachary
wasn't the judge merged I god damn it
Zachary you son of a [ __ ] what is your
point what is the point of you I don't
even want to know whatever okay where am
I gonna moon straight up straight down
straight to the boss I'm gonna kick his
ass I'm gonna purify this zone and
everybody here can go to hell
and then I Marco Polo and when I guide
the batter to his final destiny and then
beat this game and ah hell or something
like that I'm gonna oh god do I even
want to know it waits me in here Oh
ain't this nice the rivers of plastic
are looking lovely today I don't know
when the next diabolical monstrosity is
gonna come after me and nibble my nards
I hate a good nard nibbling but I'm what
is happening why is this happening are
these rivers of sugar high you're a big
fan
I like so okay wait this guy needs a
special voice give me a second
who who are you
I'm the batter and I'm come to purify
you mr. director purify but that's
ridiculous nothing justifies this
drastic measurement the Queen sent you
hasn't she naturally sir Queen it has
got to be her whoever it was I refuse
it's no question of choice you're the
monster that rules this horrible
manufactory I'm here to make you atone
for your sins
monster horrible manufactory this is my
fortress of happiness my wall against
the specters the people here were happy
before the phantoms came incidentally I
still don't understand why the dead
won't just disappear the dead of course
the ghosts I mean they're the souls of
the dead as that thought never occurred
to you it's only logical hmm so you have
nothing to do with the Phantom's of
course not I'm Enoch the Guardian is on
three my role consists like the one of
the other guardians of forming the
energy sent by the queen mother to a
solid context I am the living engine of
zone 3 the Queen relies on our kind to
make living spaces for men we are a
little like gods trying the infinite
power of the Sun to sculpt our world's
endeavor nothingness
I love that metaphor yes like gods
precisely you demented child of evil the
last grain of sand is fallen through the
hourglass of your life
certainly not no matter how strong you
are you can't overcome my massive
physique oh yeah you gotta be kidding me
that is that ah I need a break
that is too good either good ha ha
fear me like the menacing shadow of your
own extinction
oh you saw ha ha I gotta get him here
you can't Oh your face your face you're
so cute
he can't be serious here I can't kill
this guy
I can't purify even though he deserves
it I can't verify us all oh okay all
right whatever you know here we go
you're about to go down I'm gonna look
at you I'm gonna give you a good look
royal guardian of zone 3 the third boss
well isn't that just good for you good
thing I got these super-strong attacks
and I'm gonna give this to actually I'm
gonna give this to alpha because he
actually has one of the strongest
attacks of all these guys on guy this
might take a while obviously this boss
is gonna be a serious endeavor but I'm
gonna get through it as fast a crud
he's monstrous I am exceptional I think
fleeing is our only option this time
wait a minute is it can I flee can I
even do that how do I flee yeah I'm
gonna try huh what happens if I do flee
what the batter doesn't flee what the
hell is going on the batter never flees
why would the batter flee hang on a
saying some don't seem right here
he's far too strong the option of the
coward will be one ours for once flee
quickly okay whoa
oh damn this lard-ass is beefier than I
expected we'll have to find another way
to defeat him okay oh hi lard ass oh
yeah
in the shadow of death valley you shall
fear the apostle of darkness I'll kill
you batter in other words hey ah so
that's why this maze was here I don't
know if I could have beaten him I might
have been able to beat him who knows not
that I exactly gave it a good try
oh you all get away this time you
pathetic little hug prepare to join the
ghost hey uh uh yeah I'm kind of hard
whoa is a wiser side get a line through
my midriff hang on there little kitty oh
this director is fast and very robust
I'll have to fire off to be inventive to
get rid of him okay
how inventive do you want to be how am I
supposed what am I supposed to know do I
go back
do I go back now is he gonna cut me off
at the pass was I supposed to flee I
don't know if I oh that's walk-up well
hmm what does that mean for me it's
closed wait a minute it's not locked
you're saying it's closed now what's the
difference wait a minute
why did it wait what no I didn't pee
Rifai this zone yet I didn't I didn't
pee Rifai this zone
Oh Zachary Zachary Zachary I hate your
guts but I need it okay Zachary seemed
to be a little lost
okay that's know else for me to go Oh
mr. beefcake doesn't come and find me
what the hell is going on with this game
this doesn't seem right
so I'm don't seem right here oh hi what
the helling Ellington miserable right
cold water eel I had to drag my body
chock full of fat substances through the
pipes of my own domain
it was hard and humiliating but I'll eat
your hopes for survival like a block of
sugar with delight hey hey what an idiot
you've tired yourself exhausting your
strengths without taking your poor
endurance into account victories now
within my clairvoyant reach what the
hell look at how absurd this all is
you're just a puny pest I'll crush you
in no time at all your game is nearing
its end batter okay that's weird but I
even heal myself I have no idea
ah whatever I'm gonna look at you again
nope no Bluff sheltered boss okay should
have expected long I'm tiny
I'm so tiny I got a cure myself I'm so
daddy this adorable
also he's kind of terrifying if I was
the batter in that course why did he get
bigger how did he get why am I just
hitting his head
what can I hit any other nope apparently
I'm just hitting his head okay I don't
know what any of this is supposed to do
but I wanna okay this is I can only hit
his out of alley this is so weird
what the hell's happening it's so cool I
love it I love it
this game changes nice game chase okay -
I'm sorry oh why are you still poised
dammit how many no no no the kid wow
that music is wonky do you not put a
siren into my ear balls
I actually I need to hurt you and you
need to buff the attack more this guy's
actually gonna be pretty tough isn't he
okay fortune ticket on you tack on you
just like attack on Titan but attack on
you and it's gonna be a while so give me
a second so the only ring so the only
reason that this guy got so big was he
just one of the elsens that just started
eating sugar for endless periods of time
and then became this because well in the
world that didn't happen to show her and
she was addicted to sugar was a friggin
name cheer oh whoa oh I purified him but
I cut is friggin hat off okay
Aquarius card what ow no aah
hey hey so the hero has destroyed the
beast but do you know what you have just
done this zone deprived of its guardian
is now destined to disappear and the men
who live here whether they deserve it or
not will fall into nothingness
never to return you've been defeated
Enoch guardian of the third zone this
land is now pure wait a minute
I think I know what pure means oh boy
would you like to save her why not we'll
say hello again everybody so things are
just gonna fall back into nothingness
huh ain't that just beautiful
so am I an agent of the nothingness am i
literally just hero
oh it's demon babies all their little
onesies I'll have nipples why the balls
I was wrong with our teeth loser baby
onesie nipple hole tease man to kill you
how to kill a crown for you Oh secretary
the monocle humanoid spirit light
weakness against black light be the
liver okay how about I just kill you how
did I just kill you really really a lot
oh that scream is nice oh now the whole
team is asleep that's exactly what I
wanted to happen I'm gonna die that
really hurts
then well okay one of I just wanted one
of you to die to prove that you could I
didn't know if you could you need to
cure my little buddy over here who's
about to fall over anyway so I guess it
doesn't really matter on cocain
everybody's fine bunk you get sucked in
the jaw you get sucked in the jaw
yo get socked in the jaw and I'm gonna
die I think I noticed when I was when I
was starting this episode I really did
think I noticed that the whispers in the
nothingness actually have been changing
and I could have sworn I heard someone
say only one zone left don't he's the
only one zone left I'm pretty sure that
the nothingness is now driving me to
purify the entire world and return it to
the nothingness is that even good is
that even what I'm saved no idea and you
know what I don't think I'm ever even
supposed to know someone is poisoned
oh this
to be just five items I've items see
there we go that's what a batons meet
that's what I needed because I'm gonna
need a lot of that before I get to the
end of this freaking game that's am I
just gonna go through this game and I'm
gonna find ya I don't even think yeah I
don't think the rules of this map matter
anymore I don't think I need I don't
even know why I'm doing here there's
nothing on the poster good is all
nothingness
everything here is nothingness whoa
there's an Oreo that wasn't there more
where am I going
Oh walking towards the light is okay ah
deepen baby nipples okay these guys are
getting tougher and tougher to beat I
don't know but they give a lot of
experience and they're gonna level me up
very quickly which is good I think oh
wait a minute how did I how the hell did
I get here
wait a minute the tram out of order
because I didn't go to the other places
in the other area I didn't know I was
supposed to go here yet oh good a save
point that's exactly what I needed
oh god I don't know where to go I don't
know what to do I don't know where to go
I don't know what to do who know what to
do found a silent symbol that's good I
guess
I think I need to go back I definitely
need to go back because I need to go
back and see what else was in that first
area because otherwise yeah I'm gonna
need to go back anyway so wait a minute
what that no no what no what when did I
come out of the other one was that just
a bugger did I make it all why you
always gotta be three of you [ __ ]
yeah I did it
God these guys are gonna be a bear to
get through going through this entire
level is gonna be very very oh come on
sorry again
this guy is a sassy son of a [ __ ] and
he's taking forever to die oh yo is it
just a little longer to die I'm
literally gonna run out of a batons meat
I never thought that I would there's no
even reason to go in here it's empty
I've heard he better go I'll be just
shank I was back here but it's gonna be
dusted but it's gonna be a lot of doing
oh wait it'll just go a force
let me just equip my guys up so they'll
be even better all righty I'll color
first
all right virgilian colors a force
oh no not oh just one baby nipple man
one baby nibble Dean mother I can take
care of you done and done
easy peasy lemon squeezy I don't need to
worry about you anymore okay so now I
just need to get the hell out of here
and move onto the next area there was
really no reason for me to come over
here but at least I explored it and my
curiosity can go screw itself but I'm
still moving forward so that's the
important Bob okay finally moving on to
the new area because I am an idiot
apparently and I need to see everything
but oh well I guess that's a good thing
sometimes so let's just move on
hopefully there won't be too many miles
suza decide to pay me a visit what do
you even if they do I'm gonna be okay
about that I'm going to be good oh good
it's the piles of the Nothing sugar I'm
glad that I'm here reminds me of all the
lovely people that I was here to save
with my good friends Oliver Orville in
Oxnard who I'm sure are also good people
and probably not bad at all oh that
leads to nothingness yeah it's just like
the rest of this entire world leads to
nothing oh do I do get to do the fall
again who do I get to go fall again
please tell me I get to fall again I
would love to fall again those are
really fun I don't get to fall again do
I there's gonna be something completely
different at the top of this hour wait a
minute was this uh oh yeah why not I
mean the game
oh well that's another anticlimactic
well okay they're all the dead bodies is
what I was about to ask dad god I'm
leveling up so much to these guys it's
not even funny
it makes me think there's actually a
reason that they're leveling me up which
there probably is to be perfectly honest
can I go in the hole that's what she
said
not really okay into the sewers yes
jump down because I'm surely good wait a
minute comas okay whatever you know what
I'm not gonna question I'm not gonna ask
which is my destination question mark
it's not a destination bruh that is a
nothing bruh I guess this whole place
isn't nothing right this is gonna be
exactly the same it's all gonna be
closed it's all gonna be closed the only
difference is gonna be that the other
area is gonna be open let me go to the
right side first I think that's actually
gonna be more important than me doing
this cuz when I did this before it was
already turning to nothingness which
didn't make a damn bit of sense why
don't you know why is this a bad thing
it doesn't look oh I just want to say
that it didn't seem all that bad to do
this stuff because the zone seemed to be
suffering a little bit although it may
be because I was killing the guardian
and destabilizing the entire system and
everyone hates me now because I'm
actually the cause of the problem but
I'm also the solution to a problem no
one wanted to be solved so this is
probably all my fault
you're gonna die baby nipple DS man I
don't know why I feel the need to
explore absolutely everything in this
but I don't want to miss out on anything
I can't believe that I missed out at the
beginning of this episode that I needed
to go up to the top of the level because
I'm an idiot but here we go we're going
to the bottom of this level and I think
the only other place that I haven't gone
is no no wait I did go to zone 3 there's
nothing on the poster
there's nothing on any of the poster and
that is an arrow that is pointing down
why is there anything here that is
telling me what to do that is the
question oh boy
well it's good by its bunch dr. ok
bamberg Chiba go I don't know what I'm
supposed to do what what am I supposed
to do
there's gotta be uh there's got to be a
trick to this it's gonna be a trick to
this it's gotta be a trick to this trick
the destructiveness there's got to be a
trick oh I don't know what to do I don't
know what to do just gonna live it
forever it's gonna lose me around
forever and ever
okay I can still get in fights out here
apparently there's got to be one of the
directions that I'm supposed to go in
this area oh I found it I think did I
find it I think I found it this is the
one I'm right I found it Tuesday and the
grand spectral don't know what the hell
those do but I got him I got him
actually let me get you i got the grand
diagonal associated with metal grand
spectral associated with smoke grand
finale associated with plastic I think
that's all that I needed so I think I'm
actually kind of done here so if I'm not
mistaken I can move on to the last zone
which is actually the room so I think
that's gonna have to wait until the
grand finale this whole games way the
way thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done I think I'm getting close
to the end of the game but I'm not
exactly sure ah I can't wait to please
so anyway thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
my turn here now and the brain to play
games like this I'll get the best ereira
one better than [ __ ] [ __ ]